[Musik]
viele halten sie für eine der besten und
lebenswertesten Städte der ganzen USA
und nicht nur das die Stadt mit der
kultigen Golden Gate Bridge gilt auch
als eine der beliebtesten Städte der
Welt besonders für junge Menschen die
arbeiten und erfolgreich sein wollen und
was soll ich sagen das ist für euch
sicher nicht überraschend denn diese
Stadt hat nicht nur einen sehr starken
Technologiesektor sondern liegt auch
direkt neben dem Silicon Valley dem
größten techn Hub der Welt außerdem
verfügt sie über ein starkes
Finanzzentrum von weltrank kein Wunder
also dass die San Francisco Bay Area
eine der reichsten Metropolen mit einer
der höchsten Konzentrationen von
Millionären weltweit ist tatsächlich hat
die Stadt alleine ohne ihren Großraum
ein BIP von mehr als 200 Milliarden
Dollar zum Vergleich das entspricht der
gesamten Wirtschaft eines Landes wie
Griechenland nicht schlecht für eine
Stadt nicht wahr mit all diesen guten
Argumenten könnte man San Francisco fast
schon als eine Art Traumstadt bezeichnen
oder nun ja meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer nichts könnte von der Wahrheit
weiter entfernt sein denn wenn das der
Fall wäre würden wir dieses Video
überhaupt nicht machen ja es stimmt San
Francisco hat eine Menge zu bieten aber
seit ein paar Jahren verliert die Stadt
immens an Attraktivität und passt gut
auf denn es gibt viele Menschen die
befürchten dass sie denselben Weg
einschlagen könnte auf dem Detroit einst
in den Abgrund gerissen wurde die Frage
ist also was genau sind die Probleme die
diese Stadt plagen wie ist es überhaupt
möglich San Francisco in dieselben
Fußstapfen wie die Troll zu treten
scheint heute werden wir all diese
Fragen beantworten vorher habe ich aber
noch eine wichtige Frage an euch
erinnert ihr euch noch an den schrägen
Clip mit dem wir euch letztes Jahr zum
Lachen gebracht haben wie gesagt viele
waren von unserem kurzen Clip damals
ziemlich begeistert und das freut uns
natürlich riesig wie hier bei
visualpitik sind wiederum von den
schönen Produkten der österreichischen
Firma holzgern begeistert deswegen wir
unsere Freude damit nicht nur gerne mit
euch teilen würden sondern euch auch die
Gelegenheit geben möchten dass ihr diese
mit euren Liebsten teilt und siehe da
welche glückliche Fügung des Schicksals
da nah der Valentinstag und mit ihm
verbunden ein besonders attraktives
Angebot von holzgern und mit diesen so
denke ich werden wir nun wirklich alle
von den Vorzügen dieser tollen Uhren und
Accessoires überzeugen denn falls Du
unseren Link in der Beschreibung in
Video nutzt und vor den 10 Februar
bestellst kannst du deine lieben nicht
nur zu einem rabattvoll 15% auf alle
holzkernprodukte beschenken nein
Holzkern garantiert dann auch die
rechtzeitige Lieferung zum Valentin
Dienstag natürlich über den Holzkern
dann auch die stilvolle
Geschenkverpackung so kannst du deine
Lieben besonders preiswert und
stielvvoll erfreuen oder man Nut die
tollen Rabatte einfach für ein Geschenk
an sich selbst z.B ein holzkernset das
man sowieso schon lange im Auge hatte
ich meine das Sortiment ist wirklich
riesig man findet zu jedem Kleidungsstil
etwas fakt ist so gut wie jeder von uns
hier in der visualpolitikredaktion hat
sich schon in mindestens zwei
wunderschöne holzkernurren verliebt denn
schon beim Auspacken des liebevoll
gestalteten Päckchens merkt man dass das
junge Familienunternehmen sein ganzes
Herzblut darin steckt dass wirklich jede
Facette perfekt sitzt und gleichzeitig
herrlich natürlich ist die optimale
Verbindung aus Präzision und natürlicher
Eleganz was will man mehr von einer Uhr
sofort fallen einem natürlich die
hochwertigen Materialien auf aus denen
die Uhr gefertigt ist ihre Maserung
Marmorierung und das schillern von
holzstein und Perlmut jedes Stück ist
von Natur aus ein Unikat die
Naturverbundenheit von Holzkern zeigt
sich jedoch nicht nur in ihren Produkten
sondern auch darin dass ihre Herstellung
Verpackung und die Lieferketten so
nachhaltig wie möglich gestaltet sind
also lass dir diese letzte Gelegenheit
jetzt vor dem Valentinstag nicht
entgehen und beglücke dich und deine
Lieben mit dem idealen Geschenk der
Einzigartigkeit einer holzkernuhr und
oder mit einem wunderschönen Accessoire
aus dem ebenfalls schön natürlich
gestalteten Schmuck und
handtaschensortiment ganz genau es gibt
jetzt sogar Handtaschen aus Holz und die
seht auch noch super aus also zere nicht
zu lange denn der Valentinstag steht
bereits vor der Tür so und wenn du deine
Geschenke gesichert hast lass uns wieder
in unser Thema eintauchen wir werden
unsere brennenden Fragen beantworten und
zwar mit einem schnellen Blick in die
Geschichte also
aufgepasst ein Aufstieg im
Rausch die klave wurde 1776 von
spanischen siedeln gegründet die zu
Ehren des heiligen Franz von Assisi eine
Mission in der buchtt errichteten die
Mission des San Francisco und schon im
frühen 19 jahrhundert blühte der Ort
unter den Namen jerba buena auf als die
USA sie allerdings 1846 von Mexiko
übernahmen wurde sie wieder in San
Francisco umbenannt dennch blieb sie
eine kleine Stadt ohne viel Aufsehen tja
bis man auf Gold stießt durch den
goldraus stieg die Einwohnerzahl San
Franciscos von 1000 im Jahr 1848 auf
über 25 000 in etwas mehr als einem Jahr
dies stellte den ersten großen Boom der
Stadt da der zweite kam dann mit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg einer der größten
Stützpunkte der Pazifikflotte W wurde
hier eingerichtet und das brachte eine
riesige Industrie mit sich die mit der
Lieferung von Munition und Ausrüstung
für die Marine verbunden war der dritte
große Aufschwung war natürlich die docom
Revolution am Ende des 20 und zu Beginn
des 21 jahrhunderts da das silicen bin n
einen Katzensprung entfernt liegt wurde
San Francisco zu einer wichtigen
Anlaufstelle für Investoren Ingenieure
Wissenschaftler und Unternehmer aus der
ganzen
Welt ebenso war es San Francisco
allerdings auch ein Ballungsraum mit
fast 5 Millionen Einwohnern in letzten
Jahrzehnten die Wege großer sozialer
Bewegungen wie der Proteste gegen den
Vietnamkrieg die berühmte hi Bewegung
oder der Kampf für die Rechte von
Minderheiten insbesondere die von LGBTs
mit anderen Worten San Francisco war und
ist eine der reichsten und
einflussreichsten Städte der Welt und
zwar ein wirtschaftlicher politischer
sozialer und kultureller Hinsicht San
Francisco ist eine verrückte Stadt die
größtenteils von vollkommen verrückten
Menschen bewohnt ist rodat Kipling in
American Notes
1891 und dennoch hängt diese große
Erfolgsgeschichte derzeit in den Seilen
das Image San Franciscos verschlechtert
sich in rasender Geschwindigkeit und die
Frage lautet warum eigentlich was um
Himmels willen ist in der verrückten
Stadt an der Bucht los also sehen wir
uns mal die ganze Misere
an San Francisco die echte G
C es ist kein Geheimnis D in Großstädten
in der deutlich mehr Verbrechen begangen
werden als in Kleinstädten oder auf dem
Land und in San Francisco ist das
sicherlich nicht anders und es war es
auch nicht während des Goldrausch
zwischen 1850 und 56 gab es in der Stadt
z.B 1400 Morde und 1975 kam es in dieser
Stadt sogar zu dem Attentat auf den
ehemaligen Präsidenten Gerald Ford
allerdings waren vor allem die letzten
Jahre verrückt oder besser gesagt sie
erweisen sich als verrückt zwischen 2014
und 17 haben sich z.B die Fälle von
gewaltlosen raubüberf auf fast 75000
mehr als verdoppelt sagen wir einfach
dass die Nachwirkungen der großen Krise
von 2008 sehr hart waren dann ging es
zwar wieder aufwärts aber seit 2020 ist
die Kriminalität wieder in die Höhe
geschnellt und nein das lag nicht an der
Pandemie sondern an einer neuen
politischen Strategie der Strategie des
ehemaligen Staatsanwalts von San
Francisco Chaser
[Musik]
bdin seit seiner Wahl im Jahr hat bdin
versprochen flexibler mit denjenigen
umzugehen die kleinere und gewaltfreie
Straftaten begangen haben das Problem
dabei Flexibilität hieß in diesem Fall
es wurde ihnen im Grunde freie Hand
gelassen und das Ergebnis war eine echte
Katastrophe plötzlich sahen sich die
Bürger San Franciscos einem Staatsanwalt
gegenüber der es Wiederholungstätern
erlaubte ohne Strafe auf die Straße
zurückzukehren eine Person konnte z.B
auf frischer Tat ertappt werden und
dennoch sicher sein dass ihr dank Budin
absolut nichts passiert entweder man
wurde sowieso nicht belangt oder war
innerhalb ein paar Stunden wieder auf
freiem Fuß und ich bin mir sicher dass
sich viele von euch fragen was ich
dieser Staatsanwalt dabei wohl gedacht
hat nun unter anderem das hier ein
erheblicher Prozentsatz der Menschen die
in San Francisco drogenverkaufen kommt
aus Honduras wir müssen uns bewusst sein
welche Auswirkungen unsere
Interventionen haben einige dieser
jungen Männer wurden unter Anderung des
Todes hierher verschleppt einige von
ihnen haben Familienangehörige in
Honduras die geschädigt wurden oder
geschädigt werden wenn sie die
Menschenhändler nicht weiter auszahlen
Budin in einer virtuellen
Bürgerversammlung 2020 die Idee dahinter
war die Wiedereingliederung zu
erleichtern und den Druck auf das
Gefängnissystem zu mindern das Problem
war jedoch dass das Programm nicht über
genügend Ressourcen verfügte und die
Strategie nicht besonders gut umgesetzt
wurde und die Situation geret infolge
dessen so sehr außer Kontrolle dass im
Jahr 2022 die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
Bürgers von San Francisco Opfer eines
gew d oder eigentumselix zu werden auf
über 6% geschätzt wurde Nachrichten wie
die folgende wurden zur Tagesordnung 11
April 2023 kriminalitätskrise in San
Francisco kommt durch die Schließung von
wholelefoods in den Brennpunkt
tatsächlich hat die eskalierende
sicherheitskrise in der Stadt sogar dazu
geführt dass Geschäfte ihre
Öffnungszeiten ändern mussten um
Überfälle zu vermeiden oder wie im Fall
der supermarkette wholefoods eines ihrer
Flagschiffe sogar schließen mussten seit
der Eröffnung im März 2022 gab es dort
so viele Raubüberfälle dass das eschäft
unrentabel wurde trotzdem war die
mangelnde Sicherheit nicht das einzige
Problem das wholefoods als Grund für die
Schließung anführte ganz genau es gab
dann noch ein anderes Problem und habt
ihr eine Idee was die sein könnte nun
hört gut
zu der Absturz im
[Musik]
Rausch es gibt heute für Menschen die
nicht gegen covid-19 geimpft sind heute
keine einreisebeschränkung mehr in die
USA denn dieses Virus ist ganz sicher
nicht mehr das was es in den Jahren 2020
und 21 war aber was wäre wenn ich euch
sagen würde dass die USA jetzt unter
ihrer eigenen Epidemie leiden ich weiß
was ihr jetzt denkt bitte keine
Krankheiten mehr lasst uns doch in Ruhe
damit entspannt euch wir werden euch
jetzt nicht von irgendeinem neuen Virus
erzählen was das ganze Land und San
Francisco in besonderer Weise plagt ist
eine sehr ungewöhnliche Epidemie wir
haben über diese schon ein eigenes Video
gedreht es ist die drogenepidemie
genauer gesagt die
opioidepidemie viele von ihnen werden
als Arzneimittel verwendet oxyodon oder
Morphin sind die besten Beispiele dafür
beide werden zur Behandlung aller Arten
von Schmerzen eingesetzt aber leider
sind sie auch auf dem Schwarzmarkt
gelandet und haben zu schweren
Abhängigkeiten geführt aber es ist weder
das oxyodon noch Morphin das im Moment
das Chaos verursacht stattdessen ist es
eine andere Droge von der viele von euch
in letzter Zeit sicher schon gehört
haben
Fentanyl Fentanyl wurde 1959 entwickelt
und 1960 in den USA als intravenöses
Anästhetikum eingeführt es wird von
Ärzten häufig zur Schmerzlinderung nach
Operationen oder bei Krankheiten wie
kribs eingesetzt allerdings gelangte
diese Droge die 50 Mal stärker als
Heroin und 100 Mal stärker als Morphium
ist schließlich auf die Straße und löste
2011 einen neuen Boom aus als unendlich
billigere Alternative zu Heroin begann
sie Marktanteile zu gewinnen und das
Problem ist dass sie auch viel tödlicher
ist um euch eine Vorstellung zu geben in
den ersten beiden Jahren auf dem
Schwarzmarkt zwischen 2011 und 12
starben 5200 Menschen an einer Überdosis
Fentanyl und nach Angaben des CDC wurden
im Jahr 2020 in den USA mehr als 70.000
Menschen Opfer dieser Droge sie wird
häufig mit anderen Drogen wie z.B
mitamphetamin gemischt der Missbrauch
von Opioiden und insbesondere von
Fentanyl hat eine riesige Krise mit
ztausend von Opfern und einem
wirtschaftlichen Schaden von mehreren
Milliarden Dollar verursacht
kongressbericht opioidkrise kostet die
USA bis 2020 fast 1,5 Billionen Dollar
allein im Jahr 2 20 stellt dies 7% des
BIP da das ist einfach Wahnsinn aus
diesem Grund hat die Regierung beiden
begonnen Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen ihr müsst nämlich wissen dass
diese Droge nicht im Innland produziert
wird sondern mit Chemikalien hergestellt
wird die von mexikanischen Kartellen aus
China eingeführt und dann in die USA
geschmuggelt werden wir sprechen hier
insbesondere über das Sinaloa kartel die
Regierung beiden hat China bereits
aufgefordert seine chemieexporte
strenger zu kontrollieren und
gleichzeitig die Zusammenarbeit mit
Mexiko verstärkt aber was meint ihr wie
haben beide Länder reagiert nun zunächst
einmal hat China den USA seine Hilfe
zugesagt allerdings scheint Peking nicht
zu halten was es versprochen hat die
meisten Analysten sind sich nämlich
sicher dass China kein Interesse daran
hat dass die Epidemie in den USA zu Ende
geht es ist quasi so etwas wie eine
späte Rache für die Opiumkriege der
Britten tja und was ist mit Mexiko
Präsident amloo hilft den USA doch
sicher gerne oder nein ganz im Gegenteil
er zieht leider eine zynische täte Opfer
Umkehr vor seh es euch einfach nur mal
an der mexikanische Präsident macht
einen Mangel an Umarmungen in den
Familien für die fentanylkrise in den
USA verantwortlich andres Manuel Lopez
Obrador macht einen Mangel an familiärer
Zuneigung für die 70 000 jährlichen
Todesfälle durch Überdosierung
verantwortlich die auf synthetische
Opioide zurückzuführen sind die
Situation ist in den gesamten USA
verherend besonders aber in San
Francisco die Bay City ist eine der am
stärksten betroffenen Städte siht euch
an
und ja wie euch wahrscheinlich denken
könnt ist Fentanyl der Hauptschuldige an
dieser Tragödie um genau zu sein war
diese Substanz für sieben von Zeh
Todesfällen verantwortlich und so wie es
aussieht werden die Dinge nicht besser
werden Überdosis toodesfälle in San
Francisco 200 in 3 Monaten eine Schande
der Anstieg um 41% kam zustande als die
Stadt eine Beratungsstelle Schloss DIN
narcen vorrätig hatte und den
überwachten Drogenkonsum erlaubte
erinnert ihr euch noch an den Supermarkt
in San Francisco der wegen Mangel der
Sicherheit geschlossen wurde nun im
September 2022 wurde dort eine Person
mit Fentanyl und mitamphetamin in den
Toiletten tot aufgefunden und das war
kein Einzelfall sie waren ständig
überfüllt mit Menschen die diese
Substanzen konsumierten und nun versteht
ihr sicher dass sowohl die fehlende
Sicherheit als auch diese Drogen dazu
führen dass die Stadt die von vielen als
die schönste Stadt Amerikas bezeichnet
wird in einem dunklen Abgrund versinkt
tja aber glaubt ihr dass wir damit nun
fertig sind nun nein ganz und gar nicht
hört gut
[Musik]
zu die
Stadtflucht wenn ihr in einer Großstadt
wie München Frankfurt Hamburg oder
Zürich lebt habt ihr vielleicht schon
bemerkt dass die Mieten in den Himmel
wachsen doch laut dem
Weltwirtschaftsforum gehört keine dieser
vier Städte zu den weltweit teuersten
Städten in denen man leben kann aber
wisst ihr welche Stad zu den Top 10
gehört ja genau San Francisco und ihr
fragt euch vielleicht warum dem so ist
und das liegt vor allem an einem Problem
den hohen Wohnkosten es liegt auf der
Hand dass hohe Immobilienpreise nicht
aus heiterem Himmel kommen sie entstehen
normalerweise wenn das Angebot viel
geringer ist als die Nachfrage und genau
das ist in San Francisco mit Sicherheit
der Fall die Stadt Austin in Texas z.B
mit einer ähnlichen Einwohnerzahl wie
San Francisco hat seit 2010 133 000 neue
Wohneinheiten gebaut und wisst ihr wie
viele währenddessen in der City by the
bay gebaut wurden nun nur
37500 wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt hat
dies dazu geführt dass sowohl die Mieten
als auch die Hauspreise in die Höhe
geschossen sind und die Situation hat
einen derart kritischen Punkt erreicht
der sich bereits auf das
produktionsgefüge der Stadt
auswirkt im fallalle San Franciscos
wurde in den letzten 10 Jahren nur eine
Wohnung für acht neue Arbeitsplätze
gebaut und bei den Büros sieht es
ähnlich aus aber wenn ihr dachtet dass
es nicht noch schlimmer kommen könnte
hat die covid-19 Pandemie die Wirtschaft
der Stadt auf den Kopf gestellt warum
nun aus einem einfachen Grund
remotearbeit und Homeoffice San
Francisco verdoppelt seine Schätzung der
permanenten fernarbeit in der Tat haben
die hohen büropreise das Arbeiten von zu
Hause aus in San Francisco seit 2020 in
Mode gebracht einigen schätzungen
zufolge könnten schon jetzt rund 25% der
Büros in der Stadt leer stehen und wisst
ihr was das bewirkt n zum einen werden
die Straßen immer Lehrer was dazu führt
dass einige Geschäfte und Restaurants
die früher von Büroangestellten lebten
schließen müssen andererseits stellt
euch vor ihr hättet plötzlich das
Angebot von zu Hause aus zuarbeiten für
das gleiche Geld würdet ihr dann in
einer Stadt bleiben in die ihr nur wegen
der Arbeit gekommen seid und in der die
Miete fast euer gesamtes Einkommen
aufrisst nun vielleicht würden einige
von euch aus bestimmten Gründen bleiben
aber ich bin mir sicher dass viele von
euch in eine billigere Stadt ziehen
würden tja und genau das passiert auch
in San Francisco viele Fachkräfte ziehen
in andere Städte oder sogar in andere
Bundesstaaten aber nicht nur die
Arbeitnehmer versuchen zu gehen auch
viele Unternehmen ziehen diese Idee in
Betracht denn zum Trend zum Homeoffice
und den hohen Mietkosten Gesell sich
noch ein weiterer entscheidender Faktor
für Unternehmen hinzu die Steuerlast 59%
der Führungskräfte in den
Technologiebranche San Franciscos halten
sowohl die städtischen als auch die
staatlichen Steuern und Vorschriften für
zu hoch und dennoch steigen diese immer
weiter
[Musik]
an auch San Francisco steht also vor
einer wachsenen Abwanderung sowohl von
Menschen als auch Unternehmen diese
Entwicklung steckt noch in den
Kinderschuhen aber das Risiko liegt auf
dem Tisch und es erklärt dann
Nachrichten wie diese das ist der Plan
von SF um die Bürokratie zu umgehen und
82 000 Wohnungen zu bauen mangelnde
Sicherheit Drogen und hohe
Lebenshaltungskosten Schein San
Francisco in ein Reihe mit alten
Negativbeispielen wie Detroit und San
Jose zu stellen natürlich werden Sie so
schnell nicht aufgeben die
Stadtverwaltung hat bereits die
Unterstützung des kalifornischen
Gouverneurs gevin newsam in Anspruch
genommen um eine drogenaskforce
einzusetzen außerdem haben die Bürger
San Franciscos den katastrophalen
Staatsanwalt Budin bereits durch Brook
Jenkins eine neue und viel härtere
Staats Anwältin ersetzt und nicht nur
das sie wird auch von der Regierung
beiden unterstüzt die nationale
drogenkontrollstrategie vorgelegt hat
trotzdem scheint es klar zu sein dass es
um San Francisco nicht gerade zum Besten
steht und die Frage lautet daher glaubt
ihr dass es der neuen Staatsanwältin
gelingen wird die Sicherheit in der
Stadt zu verbessern wie könnte San
Francisco mit der fentanylepidemie
umgehen sollte die Bundesregierung
Eingreifen es würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr eure Meinung zu diesem Thema
mit uns und den anderen Zuschauern
teilen würdet ich hoffe dass euch dies
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt ih bitte ein Like mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es auch mit
ihnen vergesst bitte auch nicht das
tolle valentinstagsangebot von Holzkern
mit 15% Rabatt und stielvolle
Geschenkverpackung wahrzunehmen wie
immer bekommst du es nur über den Link
unter dem Video natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit der uns helf dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
natürlich auch unter dem Video macht's
gut und bis
[Musik]
bald